over the past few years people have been
waking up to the fact that sleep is
essential to our well-being in
productivity
the demand for Z's has created a brand
new seventy billion dollar industry full
of products aimed at helping you snooze
and that number is expected to top one
hundred billion in the next few years
turns out selling sleep is serious
business
Elizabeth Seagram takes her bedtime
routine to the extreme filling her
bedroom with a variety of gadgets that
help her to get the eight and a half
hours of sleep
she says she desperately needs each
night to function sleep is hard but her
job has made it a lot easier reporting
on the sleep industry for Fast Company
magazine we've begun to realize that
enough sleep is key to being optimal to
being productive it's your health that
your weight it's your productivity at
work all of those absolutely and so
suddenly people began to realize that it
was something worth spending money on
and that's when companies began to
realize you know number one we can solve
this problem and number two we can
probably make quite a lot of money it
comes with a memory foam mattress
according to Seagram we're living in a
golden age of sleep aids are we sleeping
more than because that feels like you're
spending all that money we should all be
sleeping more I think that people who
are concerned about sleeping are finding
ways to sleep better meet gravity the
premium weighted blanket that launched a
revolution in sleep there are weighted
blankets hoodie pillows sleep trackers
for under your bed and on your finger
just to name a few
every part of this room has been
carefully optimized to ensure that I get
a perfect night sleep it seems like
Seagram has tried nearly all of them so
this is a blanket that is 20 pounds and
the idea behind a way to blanket is so
the idea is that when you have weight on
your body you release serotonin and
dopamine which is relaxing there are low
tech solutions like blackout drapes and
smart lights like these from the
mattress company Casper and what's
really cool about them is so you you put
them on before you go to sleep and they
slowly dim for about 45 minutes and I
put it on Seagram's sound machine
bounces sound waves off the walls it's
literally just the plugs in the wall
providing just the right amount of white
noise for the size of the bedroom she
also takes CBD oil nightly to relax so
you get a little test kit and they give
you what they're called little flights
ok and then you try it out and then you
see what works for you before you order
the amount that you need once she's
asleep a sleep tracker under her
mattress tells her the length and
quality of her slumber and then it also
offers you advice so it coaches youth
the companies Sleep Number started
embedding all their mattresses with
sleep trackers calculating what it calls
your sleep IQ its beds adjust the
firmness throughout the night they even
offer a layer that fits under your
sheets that controls the temperature of
the bed hi Carla how you doing dr.
thenews ahamill ttan says sleep is
priceless
you know what gadget I really love it's
something we all have it's an alarm but
getting it doesn't have to be pricey
I suggest setting an alarm at night
about half an hour before bed that's
when that trigger goes off you start
winding down so if you want to meditate
if you want to write a little bit set
that ritual for bedtime and don't be
late to bed Alex - and Michael Acton
Smith started their company calm as a
meditation app but about two and a half
years ago when we notice there was a big
spike every night just before 11 p.m.
all around the world of people who are
listening to the meditations to help
them fall asleep their high-tech
solution bedtime stories and so we
thought what if we could create bedtime
tales that were designed to help people
drift off to sleep and we used to love
when we were kids to have stories read
to us right it's so soon why did we stop
exactly now it grown-ups and all
sensible there are now 144 stories
available in the call map including
tennis legend John McEnroe reading the
rules of tennis this story Wonder
narrated by Matthew McConaughey has been
listened to 4.3 million times as you
settle in under the covers with your
head easing into the pillow your body
sinking into the mattress I think that
was an inkling that there was something
interesting here Alex too says he and
his wife have listened to astronaut
terry virts story around five hundred
times it still works because it's almost
become a signal to to us as soon as it
comes on that it's it's time to sleep
calm has broadened its reach to include
physical products as well including a
partnership with gravity gentlemen put
me to sleep please there we go and a
branded mist pillow spray with essential
oils in stay awake for this just a
couple of spritzes see if I can do this
without falling over and while it's easy
to get wrapped up in the excitement well
sort of and you put it over your
shoulders as someone who has tested all
these products Elizabeth Seagram has a
recommendation for you I think it's
really important to diagnose why you're
not sleeping so is it that you're
extremely anxious if so then you need to
think about the things that you can do
to relieve that anxiety if the problem
is that you know you're sleeping hot
perhaps what you need is bed sheets that
are climate specific it appears there's
a sleep solution out there for every
problem except we haven't figured out a
way to add hours to the day to get more
sleep that I think is one thing that the
companies can't really help us with when
they do I'm in
where I will buy that yes that's what we
all need if you want to hear more from
dr. Anthony Hamilton on how sleep
trackers work and the safety of CVD oil
too you can go to our website at CBS
news.com and Jeff you asked me you know
which work yeah it really does depend on
what the problem is I'll say this the
weighted blanket I thought was really
interesting but I'm a hot sleeper so I
like the coolness of some stuff yeah I
have to be cool yeah yeah like high
sixties
yeah mid sixties you know the weighted
blanket thing is a generational thing a
lot of older people from a different
time that's what my grandmother used to
wrap and they use those for people with
PTSD
yes autistic children because there is a
comfort there and I should say I used
the sleep stories a bedtime story still
works I swear to you